So having a sex problem
is like having a toothache.
By the time you get to the dentist,
or to me, a sex therapist,
you just want to get out of pain.
But what we just went through with COVID,
that was like a sexual root canal.
I mean, we spent months
not changing out of our pajamas.
And sometimes not showering.
No wonder so many of us lost our libidos.
It's not that we're not sexual people.
We want to want sex.
We just don't want it.
In my work with couples,
one of the biggest problems I see
is that sex often stalls out
before it even gets started.
There’s a “failure to launch,”
an inability to get going
and gain momentum.
For example, one of my patients shuts down
as soon as her partner starts to kiss her.
Turns out, her boyfriend
in the eighth grade
told her she had bad breath.
Another patient of mine
is terrified of losing his erection,
so much so that he avoids any situation
that could possibly lead to sex.
But he tells his partner he has no desire,
and he blames it on work stress.
Meanwhile, he's filled with longing.
He just doesn't dare show it.
And so his partner
feels confused and unattractive.
For some of us, there just
isn't room in our busy lives
for sexual energy to emerge.
There isn’t what I call the “erotic
thread” between sexual events,
those moments when
we can express desire or feel desire,
pivot in and out of a quick sexual charge
just for the heck of it.
So, you know, it's no surprise
that by the time we actually
do get around to finally having sex,
too often it can feel reduced
to a mundane series
of predictable behaviors,
stale and drained of erotic life.
So why even bother?
Whenever the issue is a failure to launch,
what we really need is a new way in,
what I call an arousal runway.
And I firmly believe that that runway
needs to be in the form
of psychological arousal,
not just physical.
For example, we know that some women
can fantasize their way to orgasm
without ever touching themselves.
And men -- well, men
can just look at something sexy
or think about something sexy
and start to get
a strong physical reaction.
That's the power of psychological arousal.
So why aren't we sharing
more of it with each other?
Well, in the beginning of a relationship,
we really don't need to.
The newness itself is often
its own form of psychological stimuli.
But as we go on,
and as our sexual connection
starts to lose its vitality,
that's when we need to be more deliberate
about engaging our erotic minds together.
Otherwise, we might start to drift apart.
We might start to fall
into a sexless relationship.
Some of us might even start to cheat,
which is the only way that many of us know
to get back on that arousal runway.
I have rarely met a couple
that doesn't understand
the importance of psychological arousal
and doesn't want
more of it in the bedroom,
but they often just
don't know where to begin.
So I give homework assignments
that emphasize two types
of psychological arousal:
face to face and side by side.
Face to face is things
like sharing a fantasy,
role-playing a sexy scenario,
engaging in sexual role-play.
Activities that two people can do
just between themselves
with only their imaginations.
Well, that's easier said than done.
With so much shame
and inhibition around sex
that takes willingness,
it takes vulnerability,
and it takes courage.
So I often suggest starting out
with a side by side experience,
something that's a little less pressured.
Reading some literary erotica
aloud together,
listening to a sexy podcast,
watching ethical porn.
That's the kind where the performers
actually want to be there.
Recently, I was working
with a heterosexual couple
that needed an arousal boost.
They were trying to get back into sex
after having a baby.
And she especially needed help
tuning out the stressors
and getting into a sexual mindset.
But as a breastfeeding mom,
she felt totally touched out.
So she loved the idea
of psychological arousal.
She thought it would be a blast
to watch porn together.
She never did anything
like that in her life.
But for him, that was
something private and off limits,
and he was worried that she was going
to judge him based on his tastes.
So I came up with a solution.
I gave them a list of ethical porn sites,
and I asked them, "Hey, how do you feel
about each picking a scene or two
that you think would turn on the other?"
Well, not only was he willing to do that,
it led to a fascinating and funny
follow-up conversation.
He asked her, "Why exactly
did you pick tickle torture for me?"
(Laughter)
So starting side by side,
it helps us get face to face.
But then that face to face arousal,
it needs to be more
than just putting on sexy lingerie
or buying handcuffs and a blindfold.
On their own, those things
are pretty inert.
What makes them arousing is when they
enable us to tap into our fantasies,
or what the late great sex therapist
Jack Morin called a “core erotic theme.”
Sexual scenarios that uniquely
turn us on more than others,
and they hold on
to that erotic charge over time.
Well, a lot of couples say
they don't have fantasies
or they don't know
what their fantasies are.
But once you start having
those side by side experiences,
those erotic themes start to emerge
and get talked about.
Like the couple with the new baby.
Why did she end up
picking tickle torture for him?
Well, she felt like
he needed to lose control,
both in and out of the bedroom,
and he was very ticklish.
Because she was the one who actually
had to go through the pain of childbirth,
but then he made such a big deal
about being in the delivery room
and having to watch and how hard it was,
he needed to be punished for that.
(Laughter)
And because she loved the idea of just
stepping out of her nurturing mom role
and for a little while
being a powerful dominatrix.
I can't say they ever got as far
as actually engaging in tickle torture,
but I do know that they started to move
from side by side to face to face
and started to play with power
in ways that they both found really hot.
So what if you are someone
who fantasizes during sex
but you keep it to yourself?
Does that count a psychological arousal?
And what if the person
you're fantasizing about
isn't the person
you're actually having sex with?
That can be confusing.
You might start to wonder,
"What's going on here? Am I bored?
Am I not into the sex?
Am I cheating in my mind?
Should I push those thoughts
out of my head?"
No.
Our fantasies are our allies.
They help distract us away
from the chaotic world
outside of our bedroom,
and they lead us and they lull us
into our sexual bodies
so that we can tune in and turn on.
Our fantasies are our friends.
You don't fear them. You follow them.
Now does that mean you should
take your partner with you
and tell them about that secret fantasy?
Well, that depends.
It could be a great way of going deeper
into that face-to-face arousal.
But on the other hand,
if you and your partner
are just starting to dip your toes
into the shallow end of the fantasy pool,
well, then you might want to hang out
in the intermediate section
a little bit, you know,
like splash around a little bit,
get comfortable,
develop some emotional safety,
establish boundaries.
I mean, maybe you got
to make it clear to your partner,
"Hey, just so we know, fantasy is fantasy
because it's not reality, right?"
There's a line between thought and action.
And just because you happen to have
erotic themes that turn you on
and that include others,
that doesn't mean that the sex
isn't still just about the two of you.
A bunch of years ago,
I did a study with Dr Kristen Mark
on the topic of sexual boredom.
We surveyed nearly 3,500 people
in committed relationships
and found that more than 50 percent were
either bored or on the brink of boredom.
Women were twice as likely to be bored
in the first year of a relationship,
and men got bored
in the first three years.
That's a whole lot of boredom
on both sides of the bed.
But the good news,
the vast majority of respondents
were entirely interested
in trying something new
that their partners suggested.
So the antidote to boredom,
it could just be a sexy suggestion away.
It could be as simple
as waking up one morning,
looking at your partner and just saying,
"Hey, I just had
the hottest dream about you."
And then you fill in the blanks.
If it makes you blush,
just blame it on your subconscious.
The point is that sexy suggestion,
that little nugget
of psychological arousal,
that could be the difference
between lying in bed next to someone
and feeling a million miles apart,
or getting on that arousal runway
together and taking off.
So what do you think?
After a year and a half of being grounded,
Isn't it time to spread our sexual wings
and let ourselves fly?
Thank you.